I have a feeling that novellas are
similar to American soap operas
someone's always sleeping with somebody
somebody killed somebody's uncle people
too sexy for what they're doing is that
possible I feel like the this is just a
really heightened version of a lot of
Bravo's reality shows their makeup is
just a little too much like that I shot
a gang they're all wearing like cartoon
clothes you know I am 20 seconds into
this show and already my mind is blown
and why was so many close up this lady
is trying to attack a small girl in a
wheelchair because she was oh the
wheelchair got knocked over kind of
reminds me of when salons went after
jay-z in the elevator
oh she killed the old lady oh oh no she
has the scissors Oh what's gonna happen
oh my god I think he's dying because she
stabbed him in the arm which like come
on people have entered the room to watch
this kid bleed to death everyone's just
crying and yelling and screaming and
they just keep doing close-ups of every
woman's face just like ah this is
basically like WWE but in the Latin
version I think two people died in like
a matter of four minutes la boo soup
powder door so it's basically like their
version of Mary Jane and Ashley
these intros are too much for me like I
would have already flipped the channel
at this point characters are either like
not paying attention to the camera at
all or just looking deep into it there's
like this really ridiculous music
playing in the background
I can't count his well it'd been like 20
characters this is all so long like why
is this intro still going I like the
musical cues I wish I could have that in
real life just when I walk the room Loco
I know that you really like mirrors on
this show like if there's a camera angle
on one person there's a mirror behind
them where he could like still see the
other guy she just did the thing where
like you're facing away from someone and
he's
talking at you back here and then you -
she's like let me give you this one last
kiss remember me fondly cuz you ain't
never go home like this rubbing his
thumbs on her chin
cuz he's going in for a kiss she's like
oh no your goatee looks gross
she looks like she does not want this
kiss at all it's making me really
uncomfortable
I don't like one-sided kissing like you
know you're supposed to go 90 and she's
supposed to go 10 he definitely went
like 95 and she went 5 and it was
strange I mean I get why people get
hooked to these because literally
anything can happen